no sooner was there a lull in fighting
in eastern ukraine then the war of words
between moscow and kiev intensified
russian president vladimir putin
threatened to stop supplying ukraine
with gas
saying the country had failed to make
payments
but he also lashed out at ukraine for
cutting off the gas supply to rebel-held
areas of the east
and the osce has already said that there
is a humanitarian catastrophe there and
now they're cutting off gas supplies
it's starting to look like genocide
though strong words come as the week-old
cease-fire finally seems to be taking
effect
this dispute over gas supplies could tip
the balance back towards conflict
german chancellor angela mekkel has
called for calm on both sides but
speaking after meetings with the swedish
prime minister in berlin she sent a
warning to
we favor moscow efforts
but we are also saying that we cannot
rule out sanctions if things deteriorate
brussels is also alarmed at this new gas
dispute as it may jeopardize supplies to
europe too